we told you back in april about the
anti-gun extremists the biden
administration nominated to lead the
bureau of alcohol tobacco and firearms
his name david chipman tucker recently
ran down the list of some of his
unhinged beliefs
we do know that what he said publicly
tells us all we need to know about how
we got this job
in october 2018 for example david
chipman told the hill that ar-15 should
be treated quote just like machine guns
well machine guns are banned in this
country he believes ar-15 ar-15s the
single most popular rifle in america
should be banned
chipman made that remark in his capacity
as a policy advisor for an anti-gun
group one of the many funded by michael
bloomberg
in 2012 he suggested msnbc that the
secret service shouldn't carry firearms
and last year david chipman openly
mocked the millions of americans who
were buying firearms to protect their
families from the crime wave that david
chipman's party has unleashed on the
country
that guy david shipman's beliefs were so
extreme that even some democrats refused
to support his confirmation that's why
today the white house withdrew his
nomination
but that doesn't mean the butt
administration is going to stop trying
to undermine the second amendment
we'll be watching very closely to see
who joe biden nominates in david
chipman's place
and of course we'll keep you informed
hey sean hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to fox news youtube page and
catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis you will not get it
anywhere else